everybody what is going on welcome to
another Python 3 tutorial video in this
video we're gonna be talking about FTP
libs so if you're coming from a pot lid
I misspoke it's not sub processed we've
already covered that
it's FTP lib so what are we going to do
with FTP live well we're going to use
FTP which is File Transfer Protocol so
the idea of FTP is so you can transfer
files to and from a remote server now
today I wouldn't necessarily suggest
that you use FTP a lot of shared hosting
uses FTP and you can't even disable it
but FTP is not really the most secure
way or the safest way to transfer files
so if you have like highly sensitive
information it's probably using SSH and
encrypting everything but FTP is still
definitely used today it's pretty
popular you can even use SFTP which is
like secure if FTP but anyway a lot of
people still are using FTP and if it's
just something like like a basic
transfer that you're just trying to
initiate FTP live is actually a really
great thing to use with Python so with
that let's go ahead and get started with
FTP Lib so to be kind of hard for me to
show you guys FTP lives just simply
because you have to fill in like a lot
of credentials to FTP Lib but I'm just
going to show you an example that is a
working example and feel free to fill in
your own credentials I'm not going to
show any credentials in this video so
anyway well first of all we want to do
is from FTP lib import capital FTP and
what this is doing is FTP Lib it's part
of your standard library you don't have
to download anything and then we're
importing just a part of FTP Lib then
what we're going to do is we're just
under case FTP equals FTP and then in
here you're gonna put a domain domain
komm so whatever your domain name is
that's what you put in there then you
want to institute a login so we're gonna
say FTP dot login FTP login and then
you're going to want to say user equals
username and then you're going to say
passwd equals whatever your password is
then once you've done that so a lot of
people if they for a specific domain
name it's going to bring you into
exactly that domain name so the home
directory of that or the root directory
if you have shared hosting so you have
like 15 domain names when you first
connect even if you choose this domain
name here if that's your main domain
name or actually not even if that's your
main domain name really a domain name
just translates to an IP address so when
you connect to that IP address you're
going to connect to the root directory
unless this FTP user does not have
access and then they might they might
connect to their specific directory but
if this is a user that has access to
everything you're going to connect
actually to the root directory despite
what domain name you type in there so
generally the next thing you might need
to do is FTP CWD for change or well I
guess current working directory I was
thinking as far as change but you can
change it but CWD I think officially
stands for current working directory so
you can specify those CWD and maybe in
this case it actually does say mean
change working directory anyway moving
on now you can specify a specific domain
or location so you might also want to
specify a slash bar /ww slash you know
whatever in there so here let's say
you're uploading web files so that's
what you might need to do you might not
need to do that
so just obviously everyone's specific
scenario might be a little bit different
there but that's how you can change it
if you need to now I want to specify
we're going to create a couple of
functions here the first function
generally you're going to do one of two
things you're going to send a file or
you're going to receive a file ok so
first let's talk about taking files
we're just a define grab file and grab
file is going to say first we need to
know what bot what's the name of the
file that we want to grab touristic file
name equals file name dot file in fact
let's say finding that Tex just so
people don't think you have to add dot
filer and then you want to specify where
um where do we want this file to go so
the way that we can do this is when you
say local file equals open a file name
and then open with the intention to W B
so now what we're going to say is FTP
dot ret tar binary and then we're going
to make it a little bit of a command
here and it's going to be read are so
retrieve and then plus the file name
okay and then you want to specify the
where it's going and local file dot
write and then finally we're going to
specify the buffer 1024 is fine you
really can use probably even up to like
40 60 whatever but we'll use 1024 from
so 1024 will be good and then whenever
you're done you always want to do FTP
quit and then finally we also need a
local file dot close to close the actual
file here okay so let's run through this
one last time we've made a function it's
called grab file this is grabbing the
file from the remote server we specify
the name of the file we want to grab and
we're kind of doing that first just
because we want the name of the file on
the server to be the same name that it
is when we've grabbed it but you could
change these if you wanted so then we're
saying the file name is that local file
we're specifying we're going to call it
that same file name we're opening with W
B and then we're saying FTP retrieve and
then we're saying we want to retrieve
plus the file name then we want to
retrieve so this is remote and then what
we would specify next is local thing
that we want to do and we're going to do
local file dot right and then this is
just the buffer so how fast we want to
train our how much data we want to
transfer
at any given time the space of a buffer
is then we're all done we want to be
able to want to close that connection we
don't want to leave that connection open
and then we want to close the file
because again it's just like a
connection you don't want to leave that
file open otherwise you won't be able to
modify it again later
so that's grabbing files by FTP now we
can say define place file enter
parameters and again this one's a little
easier but we're still going a file name
and the file name will be file name dot
txt and then also what we're going to do
now is we don't actually really need to
do local file necessarily but we can do
FTP dot store binary and what we're
going to do here now is store space plus
the file name and actually let's see
here we've cheated let's change these to
under case for now oh as the script
actually wouldn't have worked
we'll fly to you guys store plus file
name and then open file name and then
our B here and then we'll do FTP quit
okay so so what we've done this is our
remote file local file how are we doing
it we're storing binary
what what what is it's going to store
and then the file name that we've
specified which is file name dot txt and
then open a file name we're reading
binary here into the store binary and
then we're storing it basically as the
file name that we specified okay so
again we we can grab a file well with
the following here and we can place a
file with the following here and that's
really it that's all you have to do and
let me just look through here one more
time since I didn't that I'm not
actually running this because this is
all invalid data here but this should
act this should run finally yeah and
anyway so this is how you can read or
grab files and place files from a remote
server or even really a computer if
you've got FTP on there
so that's that's all there is to it it's
actually not not too complex so if you
guys have any questions or comments or
maybe if I did screw something up here
let me know yeah so anyways uh that's it
that's all I really want to show with
FTP lib so as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support subscriptions
and some nice time